cBS Boston station WBZ reports new
details about the death of former NFL
star Aaron Hernandez inside in
Massachusetts prison law enforcement
sources tell WBZ Hernandez may have
smoked synthetic marijuana before his
death the former New England Patriot
tied-in was found early yesterday
hanging in his cell prison officials
believe it was a suicide
turning the couple is outside the
Correctional Center in Shirley
Massachusetts Tony good morning good
morning Massachusetts State Police and
the Department of Corrections are still
investigating Hernandez's death and a
single occupant cell in the building
behind me
investigators believe one of the last
people to see the 27 year-old alive is a
close friend who is now himself in an
isolated cell on suicide watch
when correction officers found Aaron
Hernandez hanging in his prison cell
just after 3 a.m. Wednesday they also
found an apparent message sources tell
CBS Boston Station WBZ Hernandez had
John 3:16 written on his forehead in red
marker that Bible verse says in part
whoever believes in Jesus shall not
perish but have everlasting life
Hernandez also appeared to have red
marker on his hands and feet officials
say Hernandez hanged himself using a
bedsheet attached to his window and
tried to block his cell door using
objects in the room his family expressed
shock and scepticism promising their own
investigation in a statement Hernandez's
attorney said there were no
conversations or correspondence from
Aaron that would have indicated anything
like this was possible and his former
agent tweeted absolutely no chance he
took his own life just five days before
his death Hernandez wiped away tears in
front of family members after being
acquitted of murder in the 2012 shooting
deaths of Daniel de Abreu and cefiro
Furtado Furtado's father appeared at a
press conference alongside attorney
William Kennedy he was a loss that he
doesn't think we'll ever be sort of
satisfied but he wants to see
accountability for his sons Hernandez
had been serving a life sentence without
parole for the 2013 murder of childhood
friend Odin Lloyd Lloyd's family is
still pursuing a wrongful death suit
against Hernandez but that could be
complicated under a centuries-old
Massachusetts law that voids his
conviction because he died before he
exhausted his Appeals that has not
deterred Lloyd's family attorney we
continue along with the civil case the
wrongful death case continues and we
really should not be affected by this
event and Hernandez died on the very
same day his former team the Patriots
visited the White House to celebrate
their Super Bowl victory his former
teammates declined to comment on his
death Norah all right Tony thank you so
much